guten morgen nach den beratungen von
bund und ländern berichten ihnen nun die
bundeskanzlerin
der regierende bürgermeister von berlin
der bayerische ministerpräsident und der
bundesfinanzminister frau
bundeskanzlerin bitten wir haben meine
damen und herren die bund und länder
haben heute früh beraten und die auch
schon in den letzten tagen ein beschluss
vorbereitet
ausgangspunkt und notwendigkeit ergibt
sich daraus dass die maßnahmen die wir
am zweiten november begonnen hatten
nicht gereicht haben nachdem wir eine
zeit lang das exponentielle wachstum
stoppen konnten und eine
seitwärtsbewegung hatte haben wir seit
einigen tagen wieder steigende
fallzahlen und ein exponentielles
wachstum und das bedeutet dass wir auch
sehr viele tote zu beklagen haben sie
verfolgen die statistik ja alle und wir
wissen dass auch das gesundheitssystem
schon sehr stark belastet ist und unser
auftrag oder unser vorhaben war ja immer
eine überlastung des gesundheitssystems
zu vermeiden
deshalb besteht dringender
handlungsbedarf und daraus resultieren
die beschlüsse die heute gefasst wurden
ziel bleibt das will ich hier noch mal
unterstreichen dass die kontakt
nachverfolgung wieder möglich wird das
heißt wir brauchen in studenzen von 50
fällen pro 100.000 einwohner in sieben
tagen und geringer
das alles hat natürlich auswirkungen auf
die feiertage das wissen wir
aber wir sind zum handeln gezwungen und
handeln jetzt auch wir haben miteinander
beschlossen dass die unterordnung der
länder bis zum 10
januar gelten werden also dann erst
einmal aber das ziel bleibt eben die
inzidenz runterzubringen das heißt wie
es anfang januar weitergeht können wir
heute noch nicht sagen sondern hängt
dann von den ergebnissen ab die wir
erreichen
wir bleiben bei den persönlichen
kontakten dabei
freunde verwandte und bekannte sich
treffen können mit maximal fünf personen
und zwei haus ständen und es gibt nur
über die weihnachtstage vom 24 26
dezember davon eine ausnahme nicht aber
zu silvester und neujahr
diese ausnahme heißt dass man über den
eigenen hausstand hinaus noch vier
weitere personen einladen kann
und zwar aus dem engsten familienkreis
also ehegatten lebenspartner partner
oder verwandte der geraden geliebt linie
das in eltern und geschwister und eltern
und kinder sowie auch für geschwister
gilt das aber es wird an alle
bürgerinnen und bürger appelliert wenn
sie andere haus stände aus der familie
zu weihnachten zu sich einladen wann
immer möglich die kontakte sieben tage
vorher zu reduzieren also eine schutz
woche einzulegen
so lässt auch neuer also die normalen
kontakt beschränkungen keine
sonderregeln wir werden ab mittwoch ab
dem 16 dezember in einzelhandel
schließen und nur noch für lebensmittel
und ähnliche dringende waren des
täglichen bedarfs offen halten es wird
auch darauf geachtet dass der verkauf
von nicht lebensmittelprodukten im
lebensmitteleinzelhandel nicht
ausgeweitet wird und es gibt ein verbot
des verkaufs von pyrotechnik vor
silvester das wird vom
bundesinnenministerium per verordnung
sichergestellt es müssen auch schließen
die dienstleistungsbetriebe im bereich
der körperpflege wie zum beispiel
friseure und an den schulen sollen die
kontakte deutlich eingeschränkt werden
ebenso bei den kindertagesstätten in das
bedeutet dass kinder wann immer möglich
zu hause betreut werden und daher werden
im zeitraum ab 16
dezember also ab mittwoch die schulen
grundsätzlich geschlossen oder die
präsenzpflicht ausgesetzt es würden
notfallbetreuung
bereitgestellt und es werden regelungen
zum distanz lehren lernen angeboten für
abschlussklassen können gesonderte
regelungen erlassen werden
kindertagesstätten wie gesagt analog zur
schule wo immer möglich sollen die
kinder zu hause betreut werden
es werden die arbeitgeberinnen und
arbeitgeber gebeten betriebsferien oder
großzügige home office lösungen
anzubieten vom 16 dezember bis 10 januar
und was die frage von mitnahme fähigen
speisen für eine tat zu hause durch
gastronomiebetriebe anbelangt so bleibt
das weiter möglich aber der verzehr vor
ort wird untersagt sie wissen dass wir
in den letzten tagen und wochen eine sie
wissen dass wir in den letzten tagen und
wochen immer wieder eine situation
hatten in der doch sich ansammlung von
menschen vor einrichtungen ergeben haben
wohl der verzehr möglich war
gottesdienste innen sind nur unter engen
voraussetzungen möglich wir werden dazu
gespräche mit den kirchen führen
das wird das bundesinnenministerium
machen
eine besondere beachtung finden die
alten und pflegeheime sowie mobile
pflegedienste hier soll eine
verpflichtende testung mehrmals pro
woche angeboten werden
wir raten von reisen ins im innern und
ausland die nicht zwingend notwendig
sind ab und die quarantäne regeln werden
dort so weitergeführt wie sie heute sind
es heute umfangreiche wirtschaftshilfe
geben dazu wird der bundesfinanzminister
etwas sagen und wir haben damit ein
umfassendes maßnahmepaket verabredet
dass natürlich die lebenssituation
vieler menschen war einfluss und das
dazu führt dass die kontakte stark
reduziert werden
und deshalb möchte ich den menschen in
deutschland danken dafür dass sie in
einer großen zahl bislang die regelung
gehalten haben und möchte alle ganz
eindringlich bitten auch in den nächsten
tagen von kontakten die nicht unbedingt
notwendig sind abstand zu nehmen und
damit einen beitrag zu leisten dass
unser gesundheitssystem nicht
überfordert wird und ich möchte vor
allen dingen denen die in den
krankenhäusern arbeiten den ärzten den
schwestern pflegern in den altenheimen
ein ganz herzliches dankeschön sagen für
die sie wird dies ein sehr schweres
weihnachten und unsere beschlüsse sind
deshalb dringend geboten um gerade wie
auch zu unterstützen und menschen mehr
gesundheitliche sicherheit zu geben
herzlichen dank ja es hat in den letzten
tagen einen sehr detaillierten aber auch
einen sehr schnellen und
einvernehmlichen abstimmungsprozess
gegeben zwischen den ländern und
zwischen dem bund und den ländern und
tatsächlich wie die bundeskanzlerin sagt
das sind jetzt einschneidender maßnahmen
für eigentlich alle beteiligten
einschneidende maßnahmen für die
familien natürlich für schülerinnen und
schüler für die einzelhändler für viele
unternehmen für die kultur die nach wie
vor noch keine perspektive haben wie es
weitergeht ist es ein wirklich
umfassender beschluss auf den wir uns
hier verständigt haben
ich möchte gerne noch mal für mich auch
die ganze situation einordnen und
darstellen was aus meiner sicht auch in
den letzten monaten schon alles passiert
ist weil ich das immer wieder ja gerade
in den letzten tagen auch gelesen habe
warum erst jetzt warum nicht noch weiter
gehen warum nicht härter warum kann sich
die politik auf dieses oder jenes nicht
verständigen
wenn man sich das anguckt was seit
februar märz passiert ist und zwar in
allen bundesländern muss man sagen wir
haben sehr schnell und entschlossen
gehandelt und zwar alle
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten wir haben dinge
eingeschränkt und geschlossen
von einem tag auf den anderen dinge die
vorher selbstverständlich waren waren
dann eben nicht mehr möglich und wir
haben in einer in einem großen einigkeit
immer wieder im grundsatz uns auf
weitere schritte verständigt natürlich
an den asta jonas
gegebenheiten es ist ein unterschied
zwischen großen flächenländern auch in
grenzsituationen oder stadtstaaten ist
es ein unterschied zwischen ländern mit
sehr hohen und ländern mit sehr
niedrigen instanzen und wir mussten und
haben immer wieder auch einen weg einen
gemeinsamen weg formulieren können und
haben vielen menschen helfen können
sowohl was den gesundheitsschutz
anbelangt als eben auch in bezug auf ya
auf perspektive wieder auch
wirtschaftliche perspektive oder für die
kulturinstitutionen wieder dinge möglich
gemacht das war und ist uns doch auch
allen wichtig nach wie vor auch immer
dort wo es möglich ist wieder normalität
zuzulassen und deutlich zu machen dinge
gehen auch aber wir haben eben an dann
auch wieder an den situationen sogar
gemerkt haben dass die zahlen sich
leider wieder nach oben entwickeln
sofort wieder nachgesteuert im oktober
im november im dezember und warum dann
nicht sofort harter lockdown ich will da
auch an das frühjahr mal erinnern wo
viele auch zu recht gesagt haben wir
haben doch gelernt aus dem frühjahr
manche dinge gehen auch nicht von heute
auf morgen so wie jetzt zum beispiel im
bereich kita und schule
familien müssen auch die chance haben
sich wenigstens ein zwei tage auf die
situation einzustellen etwas zu
organisieren für die kinder die schulen
müssen die chance haben wenigstens ein
zwei tage
diese digitalen angebote dann auch
umzusetzen an die familien zu vermitteln
die einzelnen meinte einzelhändler die
gerechnet haben mit einem
weihnachtsgeschäft müssen doch die
chance haben ein zwei tage auf diese
situation auch zu reagieren und wir
haben immer wieder auch gelernt durch
beratung durch erfahrungen die wir
gemacht haben im zusammenhang mit der
pandemie bekämpfung auch
wissenschaftliche beratung hat sich
verändert in den letzten monaten in
bezug auf kinder auf schule in bezug auf
pflegeeinrichtung und und und alles das
ist immer wieder eingeflossen auch in
unsere beschlüsse und insofern sage ich
auch man kann über jede einzelne
maßnahme hoch und runter diskutieren
warum so und nicht anders warum heute
und nicht schon gestern
oder warum erst morgen aber im
gesamtbild es ist glaube ich sehr
wichtig
auch das hier deutschlandweit zu einem
zu einer guten verständigung kommen
zwischen den ländern und dass wir
maßnahmen auch gemeinsam tragen über die
letzten monate und das ist immer wieder
auch gelungen und auch jetzt ja das ist
richtig wir haben viele dinge auch
berücksichtigt und hoch und runter
diskutiert so wie es ihn dargestellt
habe unterschiedlichste erwartungen
wurden natürlich auch formuliert aus den
unterschiedlichsten perspektiven aber
ich will es für mich auch wieder ganz
klar sagen letztendlich bleibt der
maßstab der gesundheitsschutz der
gesundheitsschutz ist das a und o wie
können wir bestmöglich menschen schützen
und wir haben und perspektiven auch
durch die impfung die er in nächster
zeit umgesetzt werden können die uns
allen auch glaube ich große hoffnung
geben dass wir wieder erneut ein stück
normalität uns erarbeiten und erkämpfen
können auch mit diesem impfschutz
aber es wird noch dauern es wird noch
dauern bis dann wirklich viele geschützt
sind durch die entsprechenden impfungen
und das bedeutet wir müssen weiter
achtsam sein und wir müssen weiter eben
auch durch einschränkungen menschen
schützen wir müssen weiter kontakte
vermeiden und in dieser kontakt
vermeidung spielt jetzt eben alles eine
rolle auch wenn wir nicht besondere
auffälligkeiten an den schulen haben
gibt es dort kontakte im umfeld der
schule und gibt es infektionen und auch
wenn einzelhändler und handwerker
natürlich die maßnahmen alle gut
umsetzen und auf regeln achten gibt es
kontakte und über die kontakte gibt es
erneute infektionen und wir sind einfach
im moment in einer situation wieder wo
wir alles was nur irgendwie möglich ist
auch einschränken müssen um diese
kontakte und damit neue infektionsketten
zu vermeiden
und insofern würde ich mich auch dem
abschließenden appell der
bundeskanzlerin noch einmal anschließen
ja es sind dinge natürlich auch
weiterhin möglich es sind dinge im
zusammenhang mit weihnachten und
silvester möglich aber man muss auch
nicht alles machen was möglich ist
sondern man muss sich jetzt auch selbst
prüfen wie man am besten sich selbst die
eigene familie freunde und verwandte
auch schützen kann
und das sind einerseits die regeln und
das ist zum anderen eben auch
tatsächlich die kontakt vermeidung im
größtmöglichen umfang und es ist nicht
in jeder sieht lebenssituation und jeden
tag immer umfassend möglich aber es ist
mit sicherheit für uns alle möglich auch
an dieser stelle noch mehr zu tun als
bisher
um uns eben auch gemeinsam zu schützen
bis der impfstoff uns allen entsprechend
helfen kann
also insofern glaube ich dass wir bei
allen zumutungen die es jetzt auch
wieder gibt für so viele menschen in
unserem land dass wir hier ein sehr
verantwortungsvollen weg auch
miteinander formuliert haben und das ist
auch meine dringende bitte das den alle
mittragen und uns in unseren bemühungen
unterstützen
ja man ist sehr kleinliche mitbürgern
mitbürger deshalb hat keine normale
ministerin sind konferenzen wie sie den
letzten vier fünf monate hatten wo wir
stundenlang geredet haben über kleine
details
heute ist die lage anders denn corona
ist außer kontrolle geraten
die lage ist eigentlich wieder fünf vor
zwölf deswegen wollen wir keine halben
sachen mehr machen sondern konsequent
handeln wir hatten letzte woche in
bayern den katastrophenfall ausgerufen
und ein journalist fragte mich ist das
nicht übertrieben
unabhängig davon dass es darum sehr
viele praktische fragen geht kroner ist
eine katastrophe corona ist eine
katastrophe die unser leben mehr
betrifft als jede krise die wir den
letzten 50 jahren zuvor haben
das sind braucht es jetzt auch eine
kraftanstrengung von uns allen eine
nationale kraftanstrengung ganz oder gar
nicht heißt das motto nicht mehr halt
hat sich ein bisschen oder versuchen
ausnahmen und schlupflöcher zu suchen
sondern konsequent entscheiden
der lock down leicht wie wir versucht
haben hat er eine wirkung
er war eine medizin aber sie hat nicht
gereicht wir waren nicht mit der
notwendigen therapie konsequenz dabei
wenn wir nicht aufpassen wird
deutschland schnell dir sorgenkind in
ganz europa deswegen mussten und müssen
die handeln
besonders schlimm und besorgt macht uns
doch alle von die zahl der todesfälle
alle drei minuten stirbt
in deutschland an corona es wird wohl
häufigste todesursache in diesem jahr
werden
das sind können wir darauf nicht
achselzuckend reagieren oder das als
statistische größe wahrnehmen wieder all
den stecken familienmenschen die auch
gerne weihnachten silvester lebt hätten
die kliniken echt sind die echten
derzeit unter der belastung teilweise
gibt es schon träsch in deutschland
nämlich dass man entscheidet wer
behandelt wird oder wer woanders sind
verlegt werden muss wir reden manchmal
über ferien und einzel details oder was
einkaufen
dabei kämpfen pflegerinnen und pfleger
und ärzte jeden tag eine schier
unermüdlichen kampf bergamo ist näher
als der ein oder andere glaubt um das zu
verhindern müssen wir konsequent handeln
wir sind nicht herzlos genau das
gegenteil ist der fall
mich persönlich und wir uns alle rührte
und deswegen dürfen wir aus
bequemlichkeit oder einen monetären
interessen keine fehlentscheidungen
treffen denn eines lehrt uns überall
kronen der welt je länger man je später
man handelt desto länger dauert es und
desto größer sind die schädigung und für
gesundheit und wirtschaft das positive
heute ist wir haben alle miteinander
klar und konsequent uns auf einen
beschluss geeinigt ein sowohl-als-auch
sondern eine richtung ist eine bittere
pille aber ich glaube diese dosis ist
jetzt richtig dass wichtiges wir machen
nicht wieder eine diskussion über
ausnahmen sondern über konsequentes
umsetzen
sind wir ehrlich seit monaten haben uns
die diskussion über ausnahmen und
details und das letzte haar in der suppe
letztlich auch die akzeptanz vieler
dieser gemeinsamen ideen geschwächt und
untergraben
deswegen ist wichtig ab mittwoch richtig
locker an in deutschland für alle
konsequent und auch klar verständlich
und anwendbar geplant bis 10 der januar
ich sagt ausdrücklich so lange es dauert
krone hält sich nicht an daten der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz krone hält
sich nicht an feiertage corona nimmt den
freiraum den besten deswegen ist unsere
oberste aufgabe bringen
jetzt das virus zu bekämpfen es hat
überhaupt keinen sinn über in der welt
gibt es zweite und dritte wellen sogar
übrigens in der geschichte war immer die
zweite oder dritte welle am
gefährlichsten haben die zweite warum
weil man es unterschätzt hat deswegen
ist auch heute wichtig noch einmal klar
zu machen dass wir in einer sehr ernsten
situation sagt es ist zeit für
gemeinsamkeit der alles jetzt in
deutschland im gleichen tot
alle müssen mitmachen deswegen aus
meiner sicht war das sehr wichtig die
gute vorbereitung die klare führung auch
durch die kanzlerin wenn ich das sagen
darf und auch dass alle mitgemacht haben
wir bayern sind besonders getroffen wir
haben heute erstmals den incidents
werden über 200 fürs ganze land
überschritten das heißt wenn man das
ausland sieht sind wie ein hotspot aber
es ist anders als bislang gedacht in den
letzten wochen war die tendenz
es wird im norden weniger und im süden
hoffentlich auch ein bisschen weniger
ist jetzt umgekehrt von süd nach nord
wanders über alles geht ganz schnell
es ist auch keine frage von besser oder
schlechter sondern nur von gemeinsam und
gleich betroffen wie wir agieren müssen
für bayern kann ich sagen wir werden die
beschlüsse maximal umsetzen wir haben in
der letzten woche bereits ja maßnahmen
vor getroffen die alle in diese richtung
gehen und bin sehr dankbar dass wir
diesen weg gemeinsam gehen können was
heißt jetzt komplett lockdown alle
geschäfte zu ab mittwoch es gab in einer
anderen der dass auch er hätte gern
machen müssen es lag aber nicht daran
dass wir jetzt mittwoch am weil ein
ministerpräsident nicht wollte sondern
weil es klare parlamentsbeteiligung und
gibt die dazu zwingen fristen
einzuhalten deswegen am mittwoch das ist
insofern auch dann ein besonderes
vorgehen weil wir damit auch uns an die
eigenen gesetze halten die vorgegeben
es gibt dafür eine umfangreiche
entschädigung des bundes auch dafür
schon ein herzliches dankeschön in den
innenstädten also alles wunder bis auf
die geschäfte sage mal dass lebensmittel
und des wirklich notwendigsten
alltäglichen bedarfs
denn die philosophie heißt daheim
bleiben die philosophie heißt kontakte
vermeiden
die philosophie heißt nicht irgendwo
sein sondern am besten zu hause mit der
familie deswegen übrigens auch in den
innenstädten nicht nur geschäfte zu
sondern auch ein klares alkoholverbot um
glühwein to go und lieber ein hopping zu
verhindern
zweitens ab mittwoch für bayern sagen
nicht dass alle schulen und alle kitas
komplett zu eine klare regelung
es ist so dass vor weihnachten damit wir
kein risiko eingehen wir wollen studien
zeigen zu nehmen dass auch kinder auch
kleinstkinder betroffen sein können
meist ohne jedes symptom aber dafür umso
leichter die möglichkeit der ansteckung
weil wenn kein symptom ist neigt man
vielleicht eher zum sozialverhalten
darauf weniger rücksicht nehmen zu
können und die kleinen nehmen wir auch
besonders gerne in den armen
das ist bei 17 18 jährigen sicherlich
etwas anders
neue studien usa oder österreich zeigen
dass dort ein erhöhtes risiko ist
deswegen vor weihnachten auf nummer
sicher gehen und wenn dann richtig wohl
nicht wieder ihr da halb oder damit
deswegen ab mittwoch alles zu alle
jahrgangsstufen und feiern mit distanz
unterricht ja mit notbetreuung das gilt
für schule und kita
dort wo es notwendig ist für die eltern
mit ausgleich eltern können auch ein
ausgleich nehmen wenn es keine
möglichkeit der betreuung gibt und sie
deswegen urlaub nehmen müssen
dann soll es einen finanziellen
ausgleich geben und appell an die
arbeitgeber ist glaube ich sowieso
wichtig sowohl über weihnachten neujahr
so möglichst viel betriebsferien zu
machen und homeoffice anzubieten wo es
nur geht
diese maßnahmen gelten alle auch in der
schule
bis 10 januar während bayern haben den
vorteil dass wir zu vier länder gehören
die ohnehin bis 10 januar zu haben es
gibt uns zeit aber auch danach kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen dass einfach alles
wieder so normal weitergeht worauf wir
allerdings besonders achten dass
abschlussklassen ihre prüfungen schaffen
werden da wird geachtet entweder durch
das verschieben der prüfungstermine wir
holen das so nach ohne zusätzliche
leistungsdruck die schülern schülern
eltern sollen sich darauf verlassen
können wir wollen alles tun dass die
gleiche bildungsqualität erhalten bleibt
ohne ein zusätzliches stress oder eine
stress mittlere abschlüsse zu haben
zu den privaten kontakten dort bleibt es
zunächst mal bei den bisherigen
regelungen für uns in bayern ist es eine
kleine ausgangs beschränkung ist gibt
das haus nur aus triftigen grund zu
verlassen
wir haben in bayern schon in den
bisherigen über 200
ausgangssperren gemacht von 21 uhr bis 5
es hat sich in den letzten tagen sehr
bewährt wir halten daran fest und wir
werden nach dem bayern jetzt überall im
ganzen land 200 hat werden wir das jetzt
für ganz bayern machen warum wir wollen
auch da die ganzen privaten feiern
private kontakte einfach reduzieren
ich weiß das ist nicht einfach und es
ist gerade für die jungen leute
unglaublich nervig und stressig aber
jetzt lieber für die nächsten wochen
wieder zusammen halten als das ganze
eine endlosschleife zu haben es hilft
uns nichts wir müssen ganz besonders an
die älteren denken an zu eltern und
großeltern sie zu schützen ist gebot für
uns alle bei weihnachten gibt es eine
verbesserte regierung die kanzel hat es
schon gesagt dort wird es besonders
schwierig seien auch die gottesdienste
ja für viele ist das eine große
einschränkung dass gottesdienste nur mit
maske mit anmeldung um abstände zu
halten und ohne gesang stattfinden soll
aber gerade in der kirche geht es um das
leben der menschen den schutz der
menschen
wir sind glaube ich ist es gut
vertretbar an silvester die klare
regelung dort wo ausgangssperren sind
gilt es auch übrigens dann ist ab 21 uhr
das ist bei uns dann in bayern so bleibt
man ohnehin zu hause
da gilt auch die gesamten anderen regeln
wir haben uns heute noch mal darauf
verständigt ein de facto parat zu haben
warum jetzt die faktoren belastet hatten
das bilden eine auswirkung pandemisch
zunächst auf den ersten blick nicht wir
haben aber den krankenhäusern den
dringenden wunsch bekommen den
dringenden wunsch dass wenn die normalen
verletzungen die es jedes jahr ein
böller gibt dazu kommen sind die
krankenhäuser nicht mehr aufnahmefähig
deswegen in diesem jahr eine ausnahme
das heißt es wird halt ein stilles
silvester das ist schade es ist wirklich
schade aber es ist glaube ich in diesem
jahr geboten
bei alten und pflegeheimen ist uns der
schutz der älteren ganz besonders
wichtig sich übrigens gezeigt obwohl
seit monaten alle länder und kommunen
die entsprechende schutzmaßnahmen
treffen ist krone reingekommen
übrigens nicht nur durch besucher
sondern man eben auch durch durch die
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter das haben wir
den grenzregionen übrigens auch gespürt
dass dort
anträge möglich sind es hat letzte woche
sie in der fernsehsendung auch das
max-planck-institut übrigens noch mal de
facto mit bestätigt haben wir klare
regeln besucher nur einmal pro tag mit
maske mit test test pflicht für
mitarbeiter mindestens zweimal die woche
und das sage hier zu bayern wo es nur
geht
auch vorhandene andere einrichtungen zu
nutzen um eine entsprechende verlegung
zu machen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren das sind jetzt klare regeln ich
glaube dass sie auch weil sie für alle
sind und ohne große ausnahmen sind
verständlicher und besser kommunizieren
mit machbar sind wir haben in den
vergangenen monaten mehr regelwerke die
selbst da eine andere minister wenn er
gefragt vor dem fernsehen
erst mal nachschauen musste ob er sie
alle parat hatte das kann man jetzt
glaube ich ganz gut verstehen
für manche ist es eine große
einschränkung enttäuschung
ich bin sicher dass es für die mehrzahl
aber eine gewisse erleichterung ist weil
sie froh darüber sind dass wir jetzt
alle den einheitlichen weg gehen
es fällt uns nicht leicht es zu tun
betont ist nicht wie manche der
querdenker gruppen meinen aus einem
politischen motiv im sinnes würde uns
freude machen wir tun ist nicht weil wir
es wollen sondern weil wir es müssen und
zwar aus echter verantwortung für die
menschen führen zu eltern und großeltern
und für das ganze land
es gibt hoffnung natürlich auch in
dieser schweren zeit die maßnahmen jetzt
den hoffnung bei dir fest überzeugt sind
sie können wirken wenn alle mitmachen
wir kommen da auch durch als deutschland
wir überstehen das auch die frage ist
nur mit welchen schäden und wir wollen
sie so klein wie möglich halten
der impfstoff ist eine hoffnung ja auch
wenn es sicherlich nicht über nacht geht
erste anzeigen sind ja da das nicht
alles ein impfstoff zur verfügung steht
wie gewünscht das heißt sie müssen sehr
klug überlegen wie wir trotzdem
konsequent impfen können die logistische
infrastruktur in den ländern steht in
bayern fast 105 zentren über 2000 ärzte
die bereit sind hat mich selber davon
nicht so überzeugt entspannt war uns die
woche da und es läuft sehr gut aber erst
muss der impfstoff da sein da muss noch
eine klasse idee alles gift werden
das wird noch gar nicht einfach werden
ich sage ihnen aber auch meine
hauptsorge ist nicht das am impfstoff im
anzug zu wenig ist sondern es am ende
sich nicht kündigen impfen werden
es wird nicht reichen nur die wohl
darauf in gruppen zu impfen
nur die risikogruppen nur die kritische
infrastruktur sondern es müssen alle
auch beim impfen mitmachen denn sonst
wird ist ein ständiges hin und her auf
und ab und das ist doch die perspektive
die wir brauchen
irgendwann einmal den großen wurf zu
machen so dass wir mit möglichst viel
schutz durch impfung und niedrigsten
zahlen die wir haben auch deswegen
übrigens fürs impfen brauchen wir
niedrige zahlen keine roten zahlen
das zu schaffen insofern das schließe
mich noch bei dem appell an
es kommt jetzt auch wirklich jeden
einzelnen an keiner steht außen vor
bitte ganz herzlich mitzumachen es ist
eine schwierige zeit aber vielleicht ist
die sogenannte staade zeit bei uns sind
bayern wenn man sagt zwischen
weihnachten neujahr die jetzt sozusagen
früher beginnt und länger dauert ist
vielleicht die beste gelegenheit daheim
zu bleiben und ein ist noch mein letzter
satz zu besinnen
das wichtigste geschenk an weihnachten
ist nicht das teuerste sondern ist die
zeit die gemeinsam verbracht werden kann
in der familie und auch das sollte man
dieses jahr vielleicht mal viel stärker
als je wieder bewerten und bis hin
vielen dank wir würden ihn heute
sicherlich gerne zum dritten advent
weniger schwierige botschaften mitteilen
aber ich glaube ganz fest dass das die
zeit das sind der ist notwendig ist das
zu tun was unsere aufgabe ist wir haben
als regierung geschworen schaden vom
deutschen volk abzuwenden
und genau darum geht es wenn jetzt diese
entscheidung getroffen werden
das glaube ich muss auch jeder wissen
das virus macht keine ferien das virus
feiert keine stille weihnacht sondern es
darauf angewiesen dass menschen sich
begegnen in großer zahl und dass es dann
von mensch zu mensch übertragen werden
kann
deshalb muss es jetzt darum gehen dass
wir angesichts der gestiegenen
infektionszahlen und der prognosen die
wir für die weitere zeit haben weitere
entschieden
klare kontakt beschränkungen gibt die
auf die verschiedenen weisen in
deutschland durchgesetzt werden dass wir
diese situation gut vorbereitet haben
ist ein beweis dafür dass der deutsche
föderalismus und die art und weise wie
wir regieren auch ordentlich
funktioniert bin sehr froh dass wir die
ganze woche über stunden lang
miteinander gesprochen haben
um vorzubereiten dass heute eine
schnelle und zügige entscheidung
getroffen werden kann
denn aus meiner sicht wäre es nicht gut
gewesen wenn angesichts der bedeutung
dieser entscheidung und der
weitreichenden konsequenzen die damit
verbunden sind wir jetzt tatsächlich
heute den ganzen tag über commerce und
andere fragen noch diskutiert hätten
hier geht es nicht um kommerz es geht um
gesundheit es geht um das leben der
bürger und dementsprechend muss das auch
gut vorbereitet und dann schnell
umgesetzt werden dass wir gemeinsam
handeln ist auch ein zeichen dafür dass
es gut abgewogene und die richtigen
entscheidungen sind das glaube ich kann
man ganz ausdrücklich den bürgern und
bürgern unseres landes sagen es sind
entscheidungen bei dem sich niemand
irgend ein einziges detail leicht
gemacht hat aber es sind welche über die
alle einigkeit haben
deshalb glauben nicht kann man gut davon
ausgehen dass es entscheidung sind die
helfen werden und die auch jetzt
erforderlich sind
dass wir die kontakte beschränken dass
jetzt der einzelhandel im außerhalb des
täglichen bedarfs eingeschränkt wird das
sich auch in schulen und kitas die
kontakte reduziert werden wobei wir sehr
darauf geachtet haben dass niemand
nachteile in seinem schulerfolg hat und
die schulabschluss erreicht werden
können
das alles sind richtige und notwendige
maßnahmen
sie haben aber auch konsequenzen um die
wir uns kümmern müssen und für die wir
uns verantwortlich fühlen und deshalb
ist mit diesem beschluss und auch mit
den maßnahmen die wir zur förderung der
wirtschaft auf den weg bringen auch
verbunden dass wir allen beistehen die
hilfe beistand und unterstützung
brauchen
ich will dass im hinblick auf die
situation zb der gewerbe mieter und
pächter in den städten deutschland sagen
sie haben jetzt eine situation in der
sie sicherlich mit ihren vermietern und
verpächter neue über die
vertragsbeziehungen in dieser situation
reden können müssen wir werden sie dabei
unterstützen
wir werden all die steuerlichen
erleichterungen die wir bei
verschiedener gelegenheit gemacht hatten
alle unter gesetzlich möglich nutzbar
machen dazu gehören auch
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten für warnt der
zilien verkauft werden können dass sie
schnell und unbürokratisch genutzt
werden können und vor allem aber wird es
eine sehr umfassende wirtschaftshilfen
überbrückungshilfe geben
wir haben von anfang an die unternehmen
in deutschland nicht alleine gelassen
mit den ersten maßnahmen zur
stabilisierung der deutschen wirtschaft
auch während des läutens dann mit den
überbrückungshilfen danach gegenwärtig
sind wir noch bei der zweiten und
überbrückungshilfe und wir haben schon
lange vorbereitet die daran
anschließende bis zum sommer des
nächsten jahres gelten der
überbrückungshilfe 3 das zeigt wir sind
bei ständiger weiterentwicklung unseres
förder und hilfe regimes angelangt wir
begreifen immer wieder neue erkenntnisse
und anforderungen auf und wir haben
natürlich auch ganz besonders die
jetzige situation im blick wenn wir den
unternehmen und geschäften helfen die
jetzt von den schliessungsentscheid
betroffen sind
es wird bis zu 500.000 euro
unterstützung im monat geben für direkt
oder indirekt geschlossene betriebe wir
werden mit der überbrückungshilfe weiter
auch all denjenigen helfen die indirekt
betroffen sind weil sie zwar nicht
geschlossen sind aber von den geringeren
handelsgeschehen auch berührt sind in
dem wir leichter möglich machen dass man
bei umsatz ein ausfällen von bis zu 40
prozent dann auch die überbrückungshilfe
in anspruch nehmen kann
die da bis zu 200.000 euro betragen kann
und wir geben dann jeweils entsprechend
der größe des umsatz ausfalles
unterstützung bis zu 90 prozent der
fixkosten die anfallen können
mittlerweile haben wir viele regelungen
getroffen die zum beispiel besondere
situation berücksichtigen dass die
veranstaltungswirtschaft was die kinos
betrifft oder zum beispiel was
aufwendung von unternehmen betrifft die
ab
freiburg haben für mit krediten
finanzierte anlagen das alles ist gut
berücksichtigt und wird unterstützung
leisten
wir werden das auch für das nächste jahr
so machen wenn dort schließung sind wird
das auch dazu führen dass diese
überbrückungshilfen zur verfügung stehen
um ihnen ein gefühl zu geben für den
umfang der maßnahmen die hier zügig auf
den weg gebracht werden und genutzt
werden können wenn es zu einer vollen
schließung für einen ganzen monat kommt
rechnen wir mit ausgaben knapp über 11
milliarden euro für einen monat und das
zeigt das ist schon eine sehr umfassend
gestaltete unterstützung ich will
gleichzeitig sagen ich halte sie für
absolut richtig
denn es geht hier um existenzen es geht
um männer und frauen die über viele
jahre und jahrzehnte sich ein geschäft
aufgebaut haben und jetzt sorge haben
dass in wenigen wochen und monaten eine
ganze lebensleistung vor ihren händen
vor ihren augen verschwindet das muss
aufgehalten werden mit den möglichkeiten
die wir haben und natürlich geht es auch
um die vielen arbeitnehmern arbeitnehmer
die in all diesen betrieben beschäftigt
sind das ist nämlich zum schluss noch
mal sagen es kommt unbedingt auf uns
alle an
jeder von uns muss seinen beitrag
leisten dass wir die bürgerinnen und
bürger schützen können indem wir die
regeln einhalten die wir miteinander
aufgestellt haben etwas abstand und
hygiene betrifft indem wir die zahl der
kontakte reduzieren so weit es möglich
ist und in dem wir damit die gesundheit
unserer liebsten unserer freunde aber
auch viele andere bürgern und bürger die
wir nicht kennen die uns wichtig sind
und von denen wir wollen dass sie jetzt
nicht von dieser gesundheitskrise
schaden nehmen dass wir die unterstützen
wir kommen dann jetzt zu ihren fragen
die erste frage hatte blank dpa
frau bundeskanzlerin das war eine blitz
mpk mit sehr weitreichenden weihnachts
notbremsen sozusagen was haben sie getan
dass die ministerpräsidenten jetzt so
schnell und so umfassend sich haben
einigen können und sind das nicht die
dinge die sie sich schon vor wochen
hätten vorstellen können um mehr im
leben zu retten und weniger tote zu
haben und die ministerpräsidenten hat
denn die kanzlerin jetzt mit ihrem
vorsichtigen kurs recht behalten im
rückblick können sie das sagen und es
gibt ja schon stimmen die sagen der
föderalismus ist jetzt stärker an die
grenzen gestoßen da sagt der brinkhaus
auch dann muss man sich gedanken darüber
machen wie sehen sie das als
ministerpräsidenten und eine frage bitte
an herrn scholz diese bezahlten
urlaubstagen wie viel können dass sein
danke ihm so ich wollte zu beginn sagen
falls nachher recherchen angestellt
werden welchen zettel ich weiter gegeben
habe an herrn brücher es war die bitte
die unterrichtung der
fraktionsvorsitzenden auf 12 uhr 15 zu
verschieben damit wir noch ein bisschen
zeit für fragen haben so damit es auch
der umfang dieser pressekonferenz
definiert jetzt hat herr blank er gleich
eine vielzahl von fragen gestellt dazu
will ich folgendes sagen ist heute
wirklich nicht der tag jetzt zurück zu
blicken oder irgendwie zu fragen was
wäre gewesen wenn
sondern es ist der tag das notwendige zu
tun das haben wir miteinander
beschlossen das haben wir gut
vorbereitet und jetzt ist es notwendig
ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass die
leichteren maßnahmen eine bessere
wirkung entfaltet hätten wir haben ja
hier gesessen und haben gesagt wir
brauchen 70 prozent oder 75 prozent
kontakt reduzierung wir hatten in den
besten fällen nur 40 prozent erreicht
und jetzt gerade auch durch das einkaufs
geschehen zu weihnachten es ist die zahl
der kontakte noch mal stark angestiegen
das heißt wir müssen jetzt diese
maßnahmen treffen sie haben eine breite
wirkung auf viele viele menschen uns ist
das bewusst aber sie werden auch eine
wirkung haben damit unser
gesundheitssystem nicht
überlastet wird und das erfordert jetzt
allerdings alle anstrengungen und eben
auch diese schnelle handeln und deshalb
finde ich heute sehr einverstanden mit
den maßnahmen die wir getroffen haben
wir haben eine große ernsthaftigkeit in
den letzten beiden tagen drei tagen das
miteinander vorbereitet und das zeigt
dass unser staat bestehend aus bund und
ländern handlungsfähig ist wenn es
notwendig ist
ich möchte das gerne noch mal
unterstützen also allen
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten war immer der ernst
der lage bewusst wir haben immer
entschieden und ich würde es auch
nochmal ganz klar sagen es gibt
niemanden der die einer maßnahme oder
den einen weg kannte der alle probleme
gelöst hat sondern wir haben in den
ländern unterschiedliche erfahrungen
gemacht mit guten und schlechten zahlen
und zwar ohne ausnahme und wir haben
unsere erfahrung miteinander
ausgetauscht und haben immer wieder nach
geschäft und so war es jetzt hier auch
ich will möchte möchte auch noch mal
daran erinnern im oktober und november
sind schon weitgehende beschlüsse
gefasst worden
es hat vor wenigen tagen noch ein papier
der leopoldina gegeben indem drin stand
und die empfehlung doch bitte am 4 0 ab
dem 24
dezember den einzelhandel einzuschränken
und sie sehen daran dass uns sehr wohl
bewusst ist wo wir stehen dass wir es
praktisch ab sofort jetzt machen so das
macht deutlich dass es hier keine
differenzen gibt wir müssen einfach
sehen herr söder ist auch schon darauf
eingegangen wir haben mit unterlagen wo
wir über die parlamente auch unsere
maßnahmen umsetzen müssen
wir haben die situation dass wir auch
die familien natürlich oder die
situation der familien berücksichtigen
müssen jetzt bei der umsetzung der
maßnahmen uns hat das in den letzten
wochen gemeinsam immer wieder
beschäftigt wie machen wir es gut um
einerseits den gesundheitsschutz zu
gewährleisten und andererseits aber auch
die menschen mitzunehmen und ihnen die
chance zu geben sich auf die jeweiligen
maßnahmen einzurichten und einzustellen
das sind weitgehende einschnitte in
vielen familien ist das nicht so einfach
von heute auf morgen umzusetzen
ich habe in meiner stadt 52
alleinlebende oder alleinerziehende
damit muss ich umgehen dass auch die
eine chance brauchen ihre familien
situation entsprechend oder ihre
situation am arbeitsplatz zu
organisieren dass es nicht sorglosigkeit
hat es die ganzen letzten wochen nicht
gegeben in keinem bundesland von keinem
ministerpräsidenten
aber es hat auch keinen gegeben der den
königsweg von anfang an wusste sondern
wir haben uns gemeinsam weiterentwickelt
und ich glaube wir haben uns in vielen
bereichen sehr erfolgreich gemeinsam
weiterentwickelt wir sind jetzt an einem
punkt wo wir sehen dass es bundesweit
mit diesen einzelnen schritten nicht
mehr geht sondern dass es jetzt wirklich
ein umfassendes herunterfahren der
kontakte geben muss und insofern gibt es
darauf auch die verständigung
wenn wir alles immer perfekt wüssten
dann wäre es ja ganz einfach aber wir
leben in einer demokratie mit einer
einzigartigen herausforderung überall in
der welt ist es so dass kroner immer
wieder neu aufflammt es gibt einige
länder die sind autoritär
die setzen auch nicht auf die
eigenverantwortung der menschen ist
sondern allein auf die staatsmacht es
gibt einige länder die sie nicht wie wir
mitten und geben von ländern
beispielsweise das im insel vor
australien habe ich gelesen ist sehr
erfolgreich unter anderem weil da seit
monaten niemand das land betreten darf
außer oder wenn unter strengsten
quarantänevorschriften wir haben eine
gesellschaftliche form eine demokratie
eine lebendige eine liberale die glaube
ich auch diesen bewährung stresstest
bestehen kann
da dauert manches mal zwei tage länger
aber ich glaube dass wir jetzt schon
gemeinsam entschieden haben
trotzdem bin ich froh dass wir zu
entschieden haben und das liegt schon
auch an der am bewusstsein aller aber
schon auch an eindringlichen worten die
gekommen sind auch vom bund noch mal
deswegen bin ich das einfach nur sagen
es war schon auch wichtig und was mich
jetzt persönlich betrifft ich bedanke
mich wirklich für die gute
zusammenarbeit auch mit herrn müller
muss ich jetzt sagen dann schwarz auch
sehr geholfen gestern normal dass da
alle sich beteiligt haben
meine position zu den dingen ist seit
monaten bekannt sagen aber auch nicht
weil wir immer glauben gewissen ist
besser sondern weil wir von anfang an
stärker betroffen waren
und in bayern zum beispiel haben die
längste außengelände wenn sie alle
deutschen bundesländer 4000 kilometer
wenn es in den nachbarregionen die wir
sehr schätzen würden riesige einträge
gibt dann ist das nur eine zeitfrage bis
es hier und dort sich entwickelt und
erlangt noch einen letzten satz keines
vor hohen infektionszahlen gefeiert wir
sind zum beispiel wie schnell ist jetzt
in einigen bundesländern vorangeht die
noch vor wenigen wochen gesagt haben
warum setzen wir uns überhaupt zusammen
deswegen ist es entscheidend dass wir
nach vorne blicken und entscheiden und
nicht die frage stellen wer hat die
bessere figur abgegeben
das ist nämlich niemanden es hilft kein
menschen und deswegen konzentrieren uns
alle auf die gemeinschaftliche aufgabe
in einem demokratisch föderalen system
ja das ist aus meiner sicht das was wir
alle hier verstehen müssen das ist eine
besondere situation weihnachten und das
neujahrsfest werden ganz anders sein als
wir das bisher erlebt haben und trotzdem
ist es richtig hier gemeinsam
entschlossen die kontakte zu reduzieren
darum andere zu schützen was die frage
betrifft was machen wir mit dem
erweiterten möglichkeiten frei zu nehmen
wenn die details jetzt zu regeln und zu
besprechen sein heute und morgen denn es
muss ja gesetzgebung zu stande kommen
damit das möglich ist in der nächsten
sitzungswoche des deutschen bundestages
der bundesminister für arbeit und
soziales ist bereits dran die frage
vorzubereiten und die richtigen
handlungsoptionen zu wählen da wir hier
einen überschaubaren zeitraum haben um
den es geht wird es sicher auch möglich
sein eine gute pragmatische lösung zu
finden
vielen dank damit möglichst viele fragen
zu wort kommen können möchte ich sie
bitten sich auf eine frage zu
beschränken die nächste frage hat der
künast cd eine nachfrage zum thema
impfen frau bundeskanzlerin andere
länder haben ja bereits begonnen mit dem
in deutschland entwickelten impfstoff zu
impfen wann wird in deutschland der
erste mensch geimpft werden
und weil es ja in weiten teilen der
gesellschaft in den sozialen medien eine
wachsende skepsis gibt es beim thema
impfen
können sie hier versichern dass der
impfstoff sicher ist kann man sich also
rote schlechtes gewissen impfen lassen
also die frage ob ein impfstoff sicher
ist wird er von den zuständigen behörden
geprüft und wir haben dafür die
europäische arzneimittelagentur die für
diese prüfungen durch und wir wollen
natürlich dass das sorgfältig geschieht
und deshalb werden wir da auch keinen
politischen druck machen und die ema hat
das ist dieser europäische
arzneimittelagentur hat gesagt dass sie
bis zum 29 12 10 eine zulassung machen
wird wir haben heute den 13 12
also wir müssen noch einige tage warten
vielleicht wird das auch etwas früher
aber spätestens am 29
dann wird natürlich auch sofort der
impfstoff ausgeliefert in alle
europäischen länder im übrigen und dann
wird sehr schnell im januar die
möglichkeit sein zu ihm also wenige tage
nach der zulassung wird man natürlich
dann impfen und ich vertraue den
europäischen arzneimittelbehörden und
den sach der sachkunde die da waltet ist
es im übrigen so dass auch die
nationalen behörden dann nochmal ihre
informationen an die europäische behörde
geben bei uns dass das paul ehrlich
institut das auch seine sein
sachverstand dort mit einbringt also da
mache ich mir keine sorgen dass nicht
der beste sachverstand der in europa da
ist auch wirklich genutzt wird und
deshalb kann dieser impfstoff dann so
zugelassen werden wir auch wie das auch
gemacht wird das wird er jetzt noch kein
impfstoff für kinder sein werden
sicherlich dann noch einige
randbedingungen gemacht werden
und da ist das dann glaube ich wichtig
dass da sorgfalt weiter
vielen dank eine frage an die beiden
ministerpräsidenten herrn müller und
herrn söder kita schließungen und grund
schulschließungen insbesondere sind ja
ein großes problem nicht nur für die
bildungsgerechtigkeit sondern einfach
auch ein betreuungsproblem für
berufstätige eltern
das haben sie gesagt wird notbetreuung
geben uns wird urlaubstage geben können
sie das ein bisschen konkretisieren wer
hat anspruch auf die notbetreuung wir
werden in zwei stunden glaube ich werden
wir mit dem so nah zusammen kommen und
werden das genau miteinander besprechen
wie wir das jetzt umsetzen wir haben ja
erfahrung aus dem frühjahr mit der note
betreuung und auch für wen wir das
anbieten können
das wort macht schon deutlich worum es
geht
in notlagen wird ja etwas oder für note
laden wird etwas organisiert wir wollen
weitestgehend kontakte vermeiden ich
sage es nochmal das ist das ziel und
insofern gibt es hier auch in unseren
beschluss die dringende aufforderung
eben auch zu sehen wie man es anders
organisieren kann jenseits des präsents
betriebes in schule und kita wie man als
familie organisieren kann es gibt
entsprechende unterstützung auch mit den
digitalen lernangeboten dort wo für den
kita-bereich es nicht anders zu
organisieren es gibt es eine
notbetreuung aber es wird ein geringer
umfang sein das muss ich so sagen
detaillierter kann ich ihnen jetzt vor
der senatssitzung noch nicht nennen es
ist wichtig dass man eine einheitliche
regelung haben wir haben ja vorher ganz
unterschiedliche auffassungen von
wechsel distanz unterricht um ähnliches
mehr beispielsweise und es zeigt sich
immer einer neuesten studien das obwohl
die kita wenig symptomatischer fälle hat
offenkundig das zeigen auch tests in
österreich sehr viele asymptomatische
entwicklungen sind das heißt er kann die
hohe ansteckung sein wenn dann ganz dann
richtig so ist natürlich richtig
betreuung ist spielt eine zentrale rolle
deswegen ist es ja ein dreiklang werden
existiert wird weiter besteht erstens in
der in der grundschule wenn es möglich
ist distanz unterricht zu machen wenn es
möglich ist wenn nicht ist es zwei die
note betreuung zu organisieren
notbetreuung ist der der es braucht
jetzt einfach mal so im eigenen
wir haben im frühjahr und sehe auf sehr
knappe systemrelevante berufe
verständigt bin der meinung für bayern
würde ich sagen wir es braucht zu
organisieren es muss nicht nur beruf
sein sondern muss einfach gar nicht
anders organisierbar ist ja wir können
die eltern völlig allein lassen
aber was ganz entscheidendes eltern
können eben am urlaub nehmen die hatten
es im frühjahr ausdruck macht bezahlten
urlaub nehmen an der für so eine
entschädigung bekommen sind es glaube
ich hilft sehr und die arbeitgeber noch
einmal dringend bitten es handelt sich
um drei tage drei tage also das nimmt
mir jetzt drei tage sind keine
wochenlange der war drei tage und für
diese drei tage glaube ich kann home
office und gemeinsamkeit auch bestehen
das gilt sowohl in der kulanz der
arbeitgeber als auch ford ist glaube ich
so dass also wenn wir die drei tage
nicht organisieren können in deutschland
eine gute betreuung zu finden entweder
schaffen es die eltern selber es gibt
tatsächlich eltern können ist nicht lege
kräfte beispielsweise da ist dann
entweder notbetreuung die möglichkeit
oder wenn es gar nicht anders geht
bleiben die eltern ihm einfach zu hause
oder an einen partner oder beide oder
eine wenn es alleinerziehende ist
natürlich dass häufig der fall
und dann bekommt man entsprechenden
ausgleich das ist sehr dankbar wieder
dass der bund auch wieder hier entgegen
kommt und das mit finanziert also jetzt
vor weihnachten sind es drei bayern hat
bis zum 10
januar ferien andere länder das auch
aber nicht alle
nicht alle haben ein bisschen zehnter
januar fehlen aber sie ist in fünf
wochen am stück oder sind wir einfach
mal sehen und die menschen haben sich ja
in dieser weihnacht silvesterzeit
ohnehin schon beschäftigt wie es
weitergehen wird also was die eigene
nächste frage hätte es von bloomberg
frau bundeskanzlerin erlauben sie dass
ich kurzen umfrage zum thema praxis
stelle und zwar können sie mir sagen es
gibt ja in der britischen presse sehr
harte vorwürfe jetzt gegen sie dass sie
unter anderem zu hart verhandelt haben
oder eine zu harte position hatten und
daher möglicherweise die gespräche
scheitern sollten nachher sprechen von
frau von der leyen und hat sonst
miteinander während sie für eine
fortsetzung der gespräche um doch noch
möglicherweise ein agreement
hinzukriegen
er ist mit sie gemeint dass sie haben
gesagt dass sie zu hart handelt also sie
also ich als person oder die europäische
union ein
also sie persönlich werden ja in der
britischen presse wenn ich es richtig
gesehen habe als hauptschuldiger dafür
dass horst präsentiert sie zu wissen
also ich habe überhaupt nicht verhandelt
und verhandle auch gar nicht sondern die
europäische kommission verhandelt die
kommissionspräsidentin sie haben es
erwähnt mit boris johnson michel barnier
für uns alle
diese verhandlungsposition hat sie auch
gar nicht verändert und dass die
verhandlungen nicht einfach sind ist ja
klar großbritannien scheidet aus dem
binnenmarkt aus und mit dem ausscheiden
aus dem binnenmarkt muss man natürlich
darauf achten dass sich auch im
zeitverlauf also wenn sich die
rechtslage zwischen großbritannien und
der europäischen union weiter
auseinanderentwickelt faire
wettbewerbsbedingungen da sind aber wie
gesagt deutschland verhandelt da
überhaupt nicht als einzelner teilnehmer
sondern für alles verhandlungen der
europäischen union
ich bin natürlich bin ich der meinung
dass die dass wir alles versuchen
sollten um ein ergebnis zu bekommen das
es versteht sich von selbst und die
kommissionspräsident sind hat uns ja
auch berichtet während des europäischen
rates und jede möglichkeit noch zum
ergebnis zu kommen ist hochwillkommen
herr rinke von reuters bundeskanzlerin
bei der ersten welle haben gerichte ja
eine ganze reihe von den verschärfungen
gekippt was macht sie sicher dass jetzt
bei diesen zusätzlichen starken
einschränkungen die beschlossen wurden
das diesmal nicht so sein wird und herr
scholz eine nachfrage zu den finanzen
sie hatten elf milliarden erwähnt mit
wie viel geld rechnen sie denn noch
darüber hinaus denn also da hat ja schon
angekündigt er kann sich nicht
vorstellen dass nach dem zehnten ersten
plötzlich alles wieder aufgehoben wird
und so sein wird wie vorher
wir leben ja immer weiter unter dem
pandemischen bedingungen und solange wir
nicht eine gewisse herren immunität
durch das impfen haben werden wir immer
unter diesen bedingungen leben wie jeder
jeweils ausgestattet sind das muss man
sehen
ihre frage nach den gerichtsprozessen im
frühjahr die haben sich im grunde erst
ergeben als wir angefangen haben zu
lockern
bei der die frage der gleichbehandlung
immer sehr im raume stand ich glaube
jetzt wo wir so ein so harte schritte
machen
da stellen sich diese fragen nicht so
stark wir haben erlebt dass öffnen es
dann immer sehr schwer weil dann eben
gefragt wird wer wird im verhältnis zu
wem gleich verhandelt und was ist jetzt
verhältnismäßig was ist richtig aber ich
glaube hier auch angesichts der zahl der
toten angesichts des exponentiellen
anstieg in dem wir wieder sind sind
diese maßnahmen so erkennbar notwendig
dass ich da nicht mit großen
schwierigkeiten rechnen zumal wir das
dann auch bundeseinheitlicher
durchführen also das sehe ich als
gegeben an zumal das auch jetzt
übereinstimmung ist mit dem paragraphen
28a des infektionsschutzgesetzes wo wir
die inzidenz noch mal festgelegt haben
und ein blick auf die landkarte zeigt
dass das geboten
es gibt einen schlüssel wir haben
einfach jetzt auf eine andere rechtliche
grundlage mit dem verweis der
bundeskanzlerin wird sehr deutlich wir
haben eine andere rechtliche grundlage
auf der wir bundesweit auch in den
ländern anders agieren können und wir
haben ja vor allen dingen auch noch mal
ein urteil gehabt zu den grundrechts
einschränkungen also sowohl beim
demonstrationsrecht wie auch bei der
religionsfreiheit und das sind natürlich
auch die dinge mit denen wir jetzt ja
auch besonders sensibel umgehen da gibt
es wie auch bei mir zb im parlament in
berlin auch ein besonderes augenmerk
drauf und wir haben aus diesen urteilen
auch gelernt aber die rechtsgrundlage
ist jetzt auch eine andere
der einsatz sei eine behauptung der
gerichte war immer die reine eine ganz
einfache schema der gleichheitsgrundsatz
und dadurch dass wir im grunde genommen
geht es gleich stellen fänden sie endlos
differenzierung und die einer der gründe
waren
warum fitnessstudio warum dies ist nicht
warum das anders weitgehend weg und aber
auch noch mal zur wahrheit zumindest in
bayern wurden von allen verfahren nur
knapp über 2 knapp drei prozent verloren
bei einer unzahl von von verfahren also
das zeigt schon auch die juristisch
dicht und wie stabil
auch die entscheidung waren weil es
immer so sie berichten immer gerne über
die entscheidung die negativ ausgeht
aber nicht über die hunderten von
entscheidungen die abgelehnt werden aber
positiv allein bei den masken gibt es
unzählige entscheidungen von überzeugten
masten gegen die immer wieder abgelehnt
worden
bis hin zum verfassungsgericht wurden
infektionsschutz verordnungen mws mehr
akzeptiert und auf ihre finanz frage zu
antworten
der deutsche bundestag hat gerade den
haushalt für das jahr 2021 beschlossen
und in diesem sinn vorgesehen für
wirtschaftshilfen 39,5 milliarden euro
und außerdem zusätzliche mittel als
maßnahmen zur bekämpfung der korona
pandemie von 35 milliarden euro
der bundestag hat sich vorbehalten der
haushaltsausschuss 20 milliarden davon
im gespräch mit ihnen dann auszugeben
entsprechend festgelegt aber da ist auch
wenn man das gesamt betrachtet eine
große vorsorge für alles was passieren
kann getroffen
die maßnahme kostet pro monat so viel
das habe ich ihm vorgetragen damit man
die dimension der förderung wahrnimmt
und auch mit welcher ernsthaftigkeit
wird wirklich das würde ich schon als
wort verwenden das schicksal vieler
unternehmen unternehmer und alle
beschäftigten in diesen betrieben im
blick haben um ihn in dieser situation
bei seite zu stehen und das glaube ich
ist schon etwas was notwendig und auch
richtig ist gleichzeitig ist es
natürlich klar dass wir immer gucken
müssen was passiert wenn es länger
dauert und deshalb habe ich ihm gesagt
dass wir doch vom deutschen bundestag
einen großen spielraum bekommen haben zu
helfen wo es notwendig ist die letzte
frage hat frau marx vom rbb danke sie
hatten es vorhin jetzt schon selber
angesprochen dass die maßnahmen die sich
schon im november getroffen haben nicht
die wirkung gehabt haben die man sich
erhofft hat jetzt haben sie ja
eigentlich eine erweiterung dieser
maßnahmen also durch weitere
schließungen
wir hatten im vorfeld auch oft
ankündigung verteilen von fc2 masken
lüftungssysteme in den schulen und was
dann noch alles an ankündigung kam aber
in der praktischen umsetzung ist es dann
da sehr still geworden
was macht sie denn jetzt so sicher oder
woher haben sie das vertrauen dass jetzt
diese maßnahmen wirklich funktionieren
dass das jetzt klappt naja das vertrauen
kann man daher haben dass auf der einen
seite via erfahrungen aus dem frühjahr
haben das heißt wir wissen wie wir jetzt
doch mit kontakt reduzierungen rechnen
können und zweitens haben wir dieses
vertrauen auch aus dem was wir aus
unseren nachbarländern sehen wo ja auch
eine ganze reihe von
beschränkung zum teil noch härtere
beschränkung als wir sie jetzt haben
gemacht wurden und wo man dann nach
einigen tagen sieht wie sich das
natürlich auswirkt was wir jetzt sehen
müssen ist dass wir natürlich noch eine
ganze reihe von tagen also an die zehn
tage haben werden in denen es weiter
steigt weil die infektionen die heute
morgen übermorgen erkannt werden ja
schon in der vergangenheit stattgefunden
haben und dann erst eine verbesserung
der lage überhaupt sichtbar ist das
heißt wir haben jetzt schon einen recht
langen weg vor uns und was die etwas b2
masken an belangt zu werden vor
weihnachten jetzt noch das hat ja der
gesundheitsminister angedeutet drei pro
berechtigten ausgegeben durch die
apotheken und die anderen dann im januar
das heißt also da wird das versprechen
jetzt in diesen tagen genau umgesetzt
für ihr kommen und noch einen schönen
dritten markt